i talked to justin justin to go brendan
wants you to go down there yep
i'm like dawg it's an hour down and an
hour back but i gotta be honest with you
i go on the road two weeks a month
and that long week that i'm home by
thursday i'm ready to get out
so i come down here really i go to
acupuncture yeah i don't mind the 405
one day yeah at 11 o'clock depends what
time
11. i leave the house at 10 i go
sepulveda instead of getting on the one
on one
i shoot and i get in the hov lane solo i
took a little hat on the [ __ ] baby
car and a little blanket a little teddy
bear with that [ __ ]
and i get in the hov lane all the way
down to venice
boom washington boulevard right to
acupuncture
and i tell you what i get down i get out
of acupuncture i walk around the block
a few times i get a smoothie i smell the
ocean air
it's good for you man it's good for your
skin it's good for [ __ ] everything
and i get back in the car
and fight that four or five before well
you just gotta you gotta make sure
you're on the road by 3 30.
because when people complain like god la
traffic's so bad it depends
it depends it depends on your timing it
depends i i'm 54. i got one from the
grade one of banana peels so
time bro is [ __ ] important hell yeah
it's valuable
you know you want to be more uh social
you want to do so many things
but you always have to throw that
traffic into the equation
i don't like getting places you know
those [ __ ] sorry traffic [ __ ]
you know l.a traffic is a [ __ ]
you got to leave early you got to plan
it i got a meeting down here monday at 9
30 a.m
you know what time i'm leaving it's what
7 30 i'll leave
5 45 [ __ ] i'll come down here early
bring it
open coffee or something get breakfast
eat down here on 26th street and ocean
avenue
get that ocean air first meeting is at 9
30.
second's at 10 30. i get out of 11. i'm
going to hit benny hannah i already got
a plan
damn some benny hannah there's a benny
hannah right on like right in
an or you talking about being hot in
santa monica yeah or
if i get out early i'll try to catch
street sports oh yeah and salami's
teaching on monday so i'll catch the
hour down there they got a shower
i watch my little [ __ ] and i go to fox
at three o'clock
damn you playing though the whole yeah
because if not you're dead in l.a
yeah man if i just go okay i'll meet
brendan you have a child now
yeah everybody wants to talk to you yeah
but you get these people that you'll
meet with
and 10 minutes into the conversation
you're like why did i get in my [ __ ]
coffee
i could have done this on the phone with
you bro this is an hour that
even if i don't go to jiu jitsu i could
swing steel clubs
i could do a couple squats i could jump
some rope i could do 30
minute little workout but instead i'm
[ __ ] here with you
talking about a script that's never
gonna happen dude or a stupid tv show
and you want to support people i know
but you have that child in the mix
yep if i'm not picking up a check at
nine in the morning i gotta drive to
school
and if i'm not picking up a check at 5
30 i have to drive to school
people there's a podcast now that you
have to be there at 6
30. and they're great guys and i told
them i said brother
6 30 am 6 30 at night by the airport
oh no and they get cancelled every week
and i said no
you got to move that up to nine because
that's an hour and a half dude i got
another
i know podcast they do it on sunday it's
my only day off they keep asking me come
on i'm like it's not happening man
my only day off sunday but when i
recharge and i have my kid the whole day
it's not happening
it's tough you hate ratings and and
guests
because a sunday show is a terrible idea
man i like my sunday late show
i do a podcast if i'm in town like this
week i'll do a sunday at nine
by eight o'clock you'll be begging me to
get out of the house on sunday
you're like honey i gotta go for a ride
and you come over we smoke pot we do the
podcasting out of that by 9 30
and i have it ready for monday morning
yeah that's about it no i like that
i like that thanks for coming down there
time management man when i first got
here
my time management is horrible and
that's part of your success is time
management
it's everything well i feel like with
you like the other night we're at the
comedy store when we got done
you know people want to be around uncle
joey like everyone gravitates towards
you so
if they want to hear stories and you're
obviously the life of the party so you
out of anyone really have to navigate
through all kind of that [ __ ]
i'll tell you who struggles with it most
encounter will admit this this isn't
anything bad counts terrible at time
answering as far as
spending energy or time on people or
projects i'm like dude this is a dead
end
like i'm telling you you're wasting your
time on this and people think he's just
not getting
some time people go well you're a bit on
the negative sometimes
after you've been here sometimes and you
see what goes into things
you have to like i tell people off the
bat it's not going to work i just don't
have time in my schedule commit to you
right now
because you're asking for a big
commitment see that's not an [ __ ] to
me that's i'm not wasting your time
this isn't going anywhere let's just you
find someone who will do this project
for you man no i'm big on my time and
you know i was married when i was young
and i blew it
and i paid dearly for that because i
don't have a relationship with my
daughter
so this time around i know exactly
how to behave myself listen the best
jujitsu class at alberto cranes is
saturday at 12. yeah
that's the one you want to go to that's
everybody could go there
and you get to row with different people
i can't make sally the baby has soccer
at 10 30.
not happening and i can't tell 11 30. i
got to go it's the whole afternoon we go
to mickey d's
yeah man she goes to old mcdonald's and
she eats
and that makes her happy so that kills
me till about 1 1 30 till i put it down
at 2 2 30. you know
i'm telling you this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing